i'm going to share with you what i
intended to say
if i had been elected in 2016.
[Music]
my fellow americans today you sent a
message to the whole world
[Music]
everybody will be knocked down the
question is will you get back up
[Music]
i want to share my life lessons with the
hope that it might help you as you
navigate your own life
i made so many gaffes and mistakes
there are steps you can take to build
confidence in yourself
to begin to trust yourself about the
decisions you will make
[Music]
this class is for anyone at any age who
wants to think about building a life of
meaning and purpose
of having a mission that captures what
you're willing to stand up for
everyone every one of you has the
ability to be resilient
[Music]
i've been you know reduced to tears i've
been frustrated beyond words but the
lesson that i've learned about getting
back up after setbacks or
disappointments is to first feel the
disappointment
don't pretend it didn't happen it did
you have to authentically
dig deep to get back up
i'm hillary rodham clinton and this is
masterclass
[Music]
[Music]
you